Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 7th lucky seven 2017 what's going on,
dude? He yelled. He said Shevon I thought seven and daddy yell.
Lucky seven. Dude, I'm going to play that fucking number, dude.
I'm going down to Christie's and I'm getting me a fucking set for life.
Getting seven of them. Why can't I fucking hear myself?
I'm screaming loud enough RNA. You know people when you're not talented,
what you have to do is yell. If you don't believe that,
watch my fucking list. Fucking whatever. How many?
I don't know how many special I've done.
You know when you talk in the amount of Shit I do,
why can't I hear myself the way I want to hear myself?
Why can I hear me the way I used to? Who am I going deaf?
Is that what's going on? How's that? Is that too much? Hello? Hello? Test one,
two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two, two.
The fuck is what this thing do.
I have an around some sort of fucking parental mode,
you know,
hearing laws is one of the number one causes of hearing loss in 2017 because
these ear buds that are all the rage with the children. Um,
I actually had time today to go over and go play drums today and I put on a
fucking add clinic. Jesus Christ.
I like practice. 9,000 things got better at nothing. That's how I practice. Hey,
let's do double bass for two minutes. Hey, let's work on singles and doubles.
Okay? Hey, let's do the jazz ride pan. Hey,
let's fucking do some bottom triplets. Alright. Just kept going and going.
But you know what I, I didn't sound that bad. I had a good time.
I fucking love that kid though. I had the small set up letter.
You guys gave me shit cause I had fucking three floor toms.
Like would you do it with boy? You fucker. You fucking toupee.
I don't own it. A toupee. All right.
You can't own it to pay it. Just it, you know what I mean? I've though,
I bet they make them really good right now, but I just,
it would just be like wearing this fucking hat. You could never take off.
You know, you wake up in the morning and you got your little roller, you know,
with the glue, you know, and you just fucking go on over your scalp,
you know you're doing that and your wife comes walking in. I mean, Jesus Christ,
I mean, she's going to be banging another guy within three days.
If your fucking woman walks in while you're glue in hair to the top of your
head, all right, and she doesn't leave you. That woman is a sane,
you know what I mean?
I love the guys who have like the fucking the to pay and then they can't even
get like the, the, like the, the sides to match it.
You know what I mean? It's like, dude, are you fucking colorblind?
Do you really think that, that, that's blending into what you got on the sides.
You know what's funny too is when you go down the to pay road, um,
they don't, I, I don't, as far as I know, they don't make any white ones.
Like if you're an older guy, so then you gotta Dye the shit you got on the side.
Okay.
Right.
So then it just makes people look at your head like you just like this guy's
like 60. How does he have jet black cow. Good Lord. Look at that fucking thing.
JJ. Um,
you know I don't like about toupees actually hair plugs now is they're too good
now. Used to be, it used to be able to tell
and you could really fuck somebody up in conversation y'all need to do,
I didn't give a fuck how smart they were led to do is just kind of look up at it
and then look back at 'em and then they would just fucked for the rest of the
conversation and those days are gone now because they got too God damn good at
it. Um, so anyways, I was playing, you know,
playing all the drums shit. Nah At this point,
cause my drum teacher is out on the road. I haven't been taking any lessons,
you know, drum teacher Davey Lich out with the night game. Um,
opening for a Dave. No, not, I was a Dave Matthews. No,
John Mayer opening for John Mayer was Steve Jordan on drums.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
You get to see Davey Lich and then you get to see Steve Jordan. How about that?
Hey, there is a fucking evening for you. You know,
that'd be enough for your Goddamn millennials. Um, yeah,
so I haven't been taking lessons, but uh, so I just,
it's actually kind of been a good thing because I can go back to all this shit
that I never fucking got down that he showed me a while developing new bad
habits. But I know I'm kidding. Anyways, I'm having a great time.
So people give me shit cause I got the three floor toms,
but this is why I did it. This was the method to my madness. All right.
I got 12 inch rack, then I got a 14, 16, 18 floor Tom. So, and then at 22 kick.
Right. So, um, I hate having to rack toms,
but I ended up ordering another one. So I've got a 12. I got 13 comments.
So now I can go big. A small people. Biggest smile I give you. They got 12, 14,
16 or 13, 16, 18, depending on whatever the fucking,
whatever song I'm going to go butcher on the goddamn comedy jam. All right.
Why can't I just have a hobby without people criticizing it?
Why can't people just say, Hey, nice drum kit that Da da.
What do you got to dirt fucking floor talk four. I go to stickiness. Jesus.
I Dunno does,
I'm trying to get out of the fucking the bottom, uh,
death spin. I went on for fucking 30 years. I'm just trying a different set up.
That's all I was doing. Got More God damn shit for that. Uh,
that and saying nuclear instead of new clear. You know,
I love the word police, you know what I mean? It's just like,
where are you gonna get in life with that? You know, it's not new killer.
It's new. I've always said no killer always said it.
It sounds right to me. Rolls off the tongue a little bit easy then. New Clear.
It's a nuclear weapon. Not Nuclear. Laughing my ass off. Let me ask you this.
Where are you laughing your ass off. Where exactly are you in your fucking life?
Cause it's dumb as I am. I'm doing all right. You know,
is there, is there a fucking job that you can do where you dot all your i's,
crossed all your t's and correct spelling. Are you going to be like,
I guess a teacher? Is that what it is?
Do I have a bunch of teachers following me on Twitter?
I don't know why they wouldn't, you know, good Lord,
these fucking people that are always like, there's so much shit.
I used to say Palo instead of pillow. Get the pals off the fucking tee.
I mean I've, I've, you know, this is shit you just saying a different way.
Cause does that mean you don't know what the fuck you put your head on at night?
Yeah.
Where does that get you?
Okay.
Can you make a living doing crossword puzzles? Those are those kinds of,
they're good. Sodoku was Sudoku. Whoever the fuck you say that,
sue, don't go to the copper. Yo right there. They got that shit
right,
dude, she's really smart. She can do the New York Times.
She can do the New York Times crossword puzzle. Great. Fantastic.
Where does that get you?
Okay.
What does that get you in life? I mean, I don't know.
I mean, tell me, tell me how that's holding me back. That's what I want to know.
And I know I'm kind of harping on this, but this is like the 900 words.
You guys have fucking correct me on it. I don't give a shit. I like new killer.
Sounds like it's more fucking like the missiles spinning a little bit more
nuclear like new, clear. Keep it clear. Here it comes nuclear. It's like, whoa.
It's a little shoulder roll in there. New Killer. I like it.
I'm keeping it fuck off. Um, you know,
do you guys like right fucking JZ every time he says Ho and you're like,
I actually, it's whore laughing my ass off.
I bet you don't. Right? Cause you're liberals, you know,
but you fucking white male fucks up. And what do you do?
You hold my fucking alabaster feet to the fire, don't you?
I've had a little bit and I've had enough of it. All right.
I've had enough of people trying to make me not sell.
Like I'm ashamed of how stupid I am. I'm not. Okay.
I saw the carrot man and I walked towards it.
I knew what I was good at.
I knew being a loud mouth fucking moron was what I was good at.
And I just did that. Okay.
I'm not going to ever be in a classroom teaching people how to spell or
pronounce shit. Okay? So let it go. The ship has sailed.
There's no hope for me. All right?
But you know the drill is the real reason people did not do when it for me.
They're doing it for them to show how smart they are.
Oh, it's not tordal.
It's turtle laughing my ass off. I know how to say that.
Fucking even fib Ian's name. Oh, bit. Actually it's not. Even if we stop it,
it's not an amphibian. And in Phoebe, in his humility, shut the fuck up.
You want this? What are those people? Are they practicing to be on a game show?
Is that what it is?
Okay.
That's like the smart way a person plays the lottery, I guess. Right?
The lottery. You just can be a dope like me going dough.
Do you see that nuclear weapon?
And then you go and let me get a fucking set for life. Right.
That's how I try to make it. Okay. The smarty pants who can do the fucking,
who can actually do the New York Times crossword puzzle is now, you know,
try to get on like wheel of fortune. Cause you know,
that's like the fucking dumbest crossword.
You can do whatever the fuck it is that a crossword? No, it isn't. Right?
It's like, yes, the letters that looks like a crossword, but it is.
But I just love that you could be smart enough to do the New York Times
crossword puzzle and then still you're going to get on there, right.
And you've got to spin a whale
and spinning that wheel. There's no intelligence. You just spin it right?
You can be the smartest person on the world and you're going to roll,
lose a turn,
well bankrupt and it's fucking over.
Um, I like watching jeopardy when, uh, you know, there's somebody just,
you just can't defeat this guy and all these other smarty pants get on there and
their whole life, they were the fucking smartest one, you know?
You know those people that don't like drink and they like,
they play board games. Like let's play trivial pursuit, you know what I mean?
Let's, let's play whatever those fucking games I got to tell you. Um,
okay.
Some of the saddest moments in my adult life as I've gone to parties and all of
a sudden they break out board games
and [inaudible]
you ever see like when somebody is on hidden video and they start looking around
like what the fuck? And the crowd starts laughing.
Like that's the look on my face. Like, yeah, then they're not going to do this.
They're not doing this other, does everybody have to play? Like,
I don't want to do this. I don't want to fuck with you.
One of my five years old, you know,
we trapped in a fucking cabin and then there's no television. No,
this is great. You can connect with you. I'll play some cards. You know,
I like how cards is like they want to go a cards.
It's just like there's a Sleazy v Vibe to cards that I've always enjoyed,
even though I don't play a lot of cards. But you know,
even like those fucking old ladies seen some old lady with their bony fingers
fucking shuffling, not even look and talking some shit.
She's got a favorite little candies right to the right. You know,
in a dish I'll, you know,
I saw an old schooled old lady today. I was in a,
I was down at the grocery store buying some fucking food, right?
And A,
this lady comes around the corner she had on like this Turquoise Blazer.
We'd like some sort of broach, I forget what she had underneath it.
She had white slacks on, white shoes and a white parse,
just old school dress to the fucking nights. She looked great.
Total fucking class act
made me miss my grandmother. My grandmother was a sharp dresser. They,
oh they, those people, they knew how to fucking dress, you know what I mean?
And then they did buy a pair of shoes and God damn it, they talk caravan,
not like us today, you know.
Well,
every black person I knew, they always took care of their fucking sneakers.
You know what I mean? Keep the fucking things. Look brand new, you know,
taken out a God damn, you know, in the nail brush scrubbing the sides. Right.
It was another white privilege moment, right.
How you could just dab dirty sneakers and that was okay. What man?
I went outside and they got dirty man. He keep watching. I mean he just,
he's always going to eat dirt out here, man.
I remember when a Patrice just give me shit for my sneakers being dirty.
I was just like, wait a fucking beauty pageant.
These like pill. If you were black and you walked out, I'm like, I'm not black.
This is totally socially acceptable for me. I get it.
You have new sneakers on. Congratulations. Um,
anyways, I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm doing this this Sunday night cause there's always,
I have a million things to do, uh, during this time of year as we're writing.
Um, season three, three, three, I've episode family, family, family. Um,
we're going to be recording episode three and writing episode four this week.
Big Shit going. We're almost at the clubhouse turn here now.
It's actually the guy coming down the back stretch.
Yeah.
You know,
I think we'll have five written and recorded by the end of this this month.
And I know what you guys are thinking. So what does that mean?
It comes out in December. Oh No, no,
there's like 40 different other things you have to do to it over the course of
the next, I don't know how many months before it finally fucking comes out.
I have no idea.
Okay.
We were joking one time. I think by the time we do the sixth season,
I'll be in my late sixties. Uh,
but I have to tell you, I really fucking like it.
I really liked doing it and um,
I really enjoyed being in the writer's room. You know,
some days it sucks when like just this shit just isn't working and my brain
isn't working and I'm fried. Some of those days suck. But generally, but then,
you know, then everybody else is saying funny shit. So that makes you get going,
you know? But I actually really, uh, enjoy writing dialogue.
Who would've thought, you know, in a way I could, you know,
some guy who says can actually write a fucking episode of television.
You know, just think about that. Okay. Think about,
think about that and then stop complaining about who's president right now.
Okay. If you can say nuclear and then you can fuck, I mean, George Bush,
you say nuclear,
the amount of people that fucking laughed at him and I want to be like, Hey,
are you bilingual? Can you also speak Spanish?
Huh?
Did you go to Yale? The guy went to fucking Yale. All right.
I don't give a shit of his dad got him in a what? He's a legacy.
He still went there. He's still got that education.
Still gotta be a member of the skull and bones.
I think that's why he had that last, he said,
cause he knew he didn't belong there anyway. He feeds us,
got pushed down that fucking road, you know.
What do you think he really wanted to do?
I think like what you do after your pres,
after your president really lets people know how much you love the job.
You know what I mean? And like he just fucking Disabil Clinton, he's still,
you know, Bill Clinton was all about the horse, you know, so he's still,
he's still out there giving speeches. Ah, I know that. And I was fucking tense.
Right. He's still out there. You know,
Jimmy Carter is building fucking homes, you know, and then he got fucking, uh,
George Bush. He's just, he's fucking hanging out like a trust fund kid.
He just sit around. Peyton, do you ever see that documentary rich kids?
Like one of the saddest fucking things I've ever seen in my life was
like
these people, they were born into such wealth.
Like one of them was, they were part of the Johnson and Johnson family,
which I think a lot of people don't know what that is.
But like when I was growing up, everything was made by Johnson and Johnson.
I'm sure they got bought out, whatever. But when,
um,
I guess when they bought that out, Johnson and Johnson,
they built it in that their kids would always just be taken care of and would
have a, I don't know, a position. The competition, they were just getting money.
It's this fucking beast that Johnson and Johnson built just it,
the inertia of that fucking thing,
just tearing through the capitalist economy right.
Was just so big that they just, they just like, if they get the Skimm,
remember fucking casino, the Skim,
the kids still get the skim and the fucking skim alone.
They get a little fucking duffle bag of cash that they don't ever have to work
in their life. Right. And I, you would think that, that'd be, dude,
that would be the fucking greatest thing ever.
That would be the greatest thing ever. And um,
it kind of turned out that it wasn't,
I think it would be the greatest thing ever if you actually a live the other way
first. But even then, I think, I think it'll get boring after a while.
Do you think you could do it?
I think if you just had enough money where you never had to work again, my
thought would be, well, the next big thing in my life is I'm going to die.
That's an the next eventful thing. I have no deadlines.
I have no worries.
Oh Man. My F I would get like psycho obsessed with shit,
you know, like I do already. But I then like my real life takes over.
They don't fucking play dumb shit. Oh,
they'd run fucking hours and I find blame all fucking time.
And then like my real life to a,
you got to go into the writer's room and then it eases it off.
Like if I just fucking was sitting there,
like when I was talking to you guys about that building in Manhattan,
the one that looks like a giant cigarette, um, something park avenue.
And I was like,
what the fuck is that thing that thing's bigger than the Freedom Tower?
And, uh, I went back and I looked at those pictures that they have from the,
the penthouse in that building and that bath tub you had backed up everybody has
now, which it's shaped like a, like the fuck in Chicago Bears Stadium,
you know that one, that freestanding one is not on legs. Like it's, it's big.
The ladies love it evidently. Right.
And it's right up on the fucking window and you can just look out all the way
south of Manhattan past the Statue of Liberty to see the fucking, you know,
whenever the Germans come to attack us against the, you know,
this person in the fucking top is going to see at first, right. The Japanese,
I should say, I just figured that side of the country, you know,
the Germans would be coming right with their nuclear weapons
actually. Why would you bring it over here?
You just fucking shoot it off when you, um, anyway, so I was just looking at it.
I was just trying to imagine sitting in that tub,
taking a bath that that would be one of the saddest experiences you could,
you could possibly have.
It looks so fucking lonely. First one I saw, I was like, Holy Shit,
that's fucking unbelievable. That looks like, I feel like I'm in a helicopter,
but you're like in a, in a fucking building.
But then just being that high up, you can't even hear the city anymore.
Just how quiet it would be. You know, you literally,
you're getting to that love, that thing that astronaut.
See you're like to astronauts.
They would go out and they would orbit the earth and they would just look down
at it and they will above all the bullshit, all the politics,
all the religion, all the fucking war, all the disease, all the suffering.
And they looked down and they were able to see how beautiful it was.
The paradise that we actually live in.
We just sit here with all this petty shit and like these guys would come back
and they couldn't talk to anybody about it.
Couldn't give anybody else that perspective unless they talked to a fellow
astronauts. So then they would just be, you know,
pulling up to a stoplight and they would see something.
They would just randomly start crying.
I think that would happen if I took a bath that high above Fuckin Manhattan.
Yeah.
And you just looking out August man. Why Kid? Why cousin?
Great.
Why don't we ever do the right DB philosophically just stay.
Why don't we do the right thing? Why are we always like, you can't, that's,
that's the, that's the scary thing.
That's why all pilots are a little fucking weird.
There's something weird about going up there and just looking down at all of it,
you know, like a higher being.
Then you also get to see what the fuck would do to the planet.
It's a really fucking, it's a weird thing. Um,
and then you combine that with the fact that you've taken a bath.
One of the most relaxing thing ever. Just looking down at this fucking terror.
I Dunno. I also kind of wonder like with global warming,
like what's going to happen, you know?
Yeah.
I'm sorry. Climate Change. I didn't mean to shock you by saying global warming.
I hope I didn't ruin your day with those two fucking words.
Let me say climate change so you can fucking relax a little bit.
Still don't understand why they say that climate change.
It's like when Halliburton changed its fucking name, right?
Well they changed it to peaches and cream. I can't fucking remember anyways. Um,
I was just thinking that like the more like severe the weather's going to get.
Like what will that mean? You know,
like we can expect some crazy storms we've never fucking seen before.
I wonder if they took that into consideration when they built that goddamn thing
that all of a sudden, you know, yeah, we're going to start getting like,
like steroid era Mark McGuire era fucking,
you know, hurricanes.
Okay.
You know,
and this is going to be a category 19 and you're up there taking a fucking bath.
Okay.
Watching this shit rolling in.
You're going to go right out that fucking window in that tub
all the way down to the fucking pavement.
But what a way to go that porsan thing. It'd be like the cartoons.
We try to get the bathwater back into the fucking tub.
It will be a hell of a death. I honestly think if there is a god, you know,
he would fucking take extra time.
He would take extra time with you just being like, ah,
like just watching the game, film your death going
I a just being like, you know, I've seen people die for since the beginning.
Man, I this, this, this is, this is one is this is definitely,
I'd never seen this one before.
I never seen somebody in a bathtub at 1,350 feet.
Yeah,
I dunno. I Dunno why I'm obsessed with that fucking building. It's just,
I dunno, there was just something about it.
And then the fact that they can't sell the one underneath that is the funniest
shit ever because who the fuck is gonna pay $85 million and still have somebody
living above and below you? You fucking knock it off up there.
What am I paying for you? Um, anyways,
how about those red socks? Huh? How bout those red socks?
But you know something, they want fame. They, they're undefeated.
They went five in a row undefeated this month. All right. And I went on the,
I went on the old Internet there, right. And, um,
I see, I looked up the standings, the baseball standings yet that, that,
that would [inaudible] baseball one right this weekend, baseball duty duty
due to the [inaudible] Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah. But I do to do today
[inaudible] to do,
if you saw the highlights and actually heard an orchestra playing one,
I just played it or tried to sync, it'd be tremendous.
So [inaudible] the Houston Astros evidently are the other beasts of the American
league. Um,
I was all excited that we swept a white sox and just realized that [inaudible]
41 in 68, I guess that's not such a big deal,
but we did what we were supposed to do. We kicked the shit out of a man.
We want sex in a row, gone eight and two last 10 picked up three games on them.
Fucking Yankees. You see fucking Aaron judge 35th home run today
at the same trajectory as a base hit except for one out of the park telling you
it's like fucking Paul Bunyan coming to the goddamn plate.
I'm loving the Indians in first place. That'd be great to see them win. One.
Let's test my knowledge. All right. Red Sox. Last world series, 2013 Yankees,
2009 Tampa Bay. Never sit down.
Shut the fuck up. Baltimore Orioles. 1983 okay.
Toronto Blue Jays, they went back to back 92 93. Cleveland Indians,
1948 Kansas City royal
warranty.
15 last year. It was a cubs, right? Minnesota twins.
Uh, 1991.
Detroit, 1984. Chicago White Sox, 2005 Houston Astros.
Never say shut the fuck up.
Seattle mariners never sit down. Shut the fuck.
So childless Los Angeles angels.
2002 Texas Rangers. You know what? Never sit down.
Shut up.
Bug Up Oakland 89 okay.
Washington centers never sit down. Shut the fuck up. Miami Marlins,
was it 2003 Atlanta Braves is 95 New York mets.
Every red sox fan knows that's 1986. Philadelphia Phillies,
2008 2016 Milwaukee brewers never sit down and shut the fuck up.
St Louis Cardinals. Oh Shit. I Dunno this one.
They always win the fucking thing.
Was it 2006 or they wanted this decade. Pittsburgh pirates, I dunno.
71.
The reds was 1990 the Dodgers was a 88 Colorado Rockies.
Never Arizona Diamondbacks. 2001.
The one time I ever rooted for the Yankees cause it was right after nine 11.
I was like, oh, it gives a fuck. I root for him. San Diego Padres, never.
San Francisco giants. I want to say they want it.
2010 2012 and 2014 is that right?
15 was a royal 16 was a cubs. Yeah, I'd say 2040.
That's not bad for somebody who doesn't fucking watch baseball. Um,
was that boring to you? I'm sorry. Let me, uh, let me,
do you know if that was boring enough?
Let me get to one of the most exciting parts of this podcast. Listening to me.
Read out loud. All right, here we go. We've got one, two, three, four,
one, two, three, four, one, two, three, four.
I was talking to someone about that the other day when somebody got a doorbell
like that, when I had a paper route when I was a kid,
I thought that that meant they were rich. They didn't just go bang,
bong or the fucking dentist real one.
If they actually had the one that went, Ding Dong, Ding Dong, Ding Dong,
Ding Dong.
You know what's so weird is that answered the door before it ended and then
they're fucking looking at you. All right. Oh look who's here, but oh, popo
[inaudible]
taken a bath at 2000 feet due to [inaudible]
the me undies.
Uh, getting a hooker. I'm in the skeet Gaza. God. 95 million bucks.
I'm fucking lonely. I'm banging hookers and I gave him a pair of hooker.
Me On ds and their pussies are velvety. Soft. Sorry.
Alright. You want to look good in your underwear though? Yeah.
And be comfortable. Right? But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies. August is national underwear month.
What did they have to pay to get that at? Mean?
This is national ghetto fucking job. Man. They always have something.
This is a international, this is like a national, uh,
fucking blueberry pancake day. Yeah.
I'm so fucking sick of saying I have to look that up.
I'm just in a place in my house where I can't get internet, you know,
by the way, who the fuck knew the Dodgers were playing as well as I did.
You know, cause they, they, they, if you don't have spectrum,
you can't fucking watch. 'Em out here.
August is national underwear month and to celebrate the undies is jerking me
undies is making it easier than ever to try the world's most comfortable
underwear by giving you a risk free guarantee. All national underwear,
month long. If you don't love your Mandy's, they're free.
A I love that. Keep a man. We don't want to back me on these. Gets it.
Do I return them? And they just go grubs and they hang up on your cable B.
And these are made from Lin zig micro modal, modal,
a sustainably sourced,
naturally soft fabric that's proven to be three times softer than cotton.
How do they do that? None of they tickle somebody's ball bag with each one.
You know, while he laughed a little more with Mike,
three times as much micro motel is in an all natural breathable ecofriendly
fabric extruded from Austrian peach trees that actually inhibits odor.
Okay.
You know, he would be into just too fucking smart time sometimes.
Who the fuck figured out to do that? Eco-Friendly fabric. Okay.
That means it's biodegradable extruded from Austrian beach trees that actually
inhibits odor. So we'll see.
We had like 10 subjects with smelly balls and like you fucking smelled their
balls, JJ Christ. And then you put that on and be like, you know,
it's not as bad. No Stinky undies, just soft and cool and cozy.
Male host read this line.
And for the fellows and for the fellows,
Mandy's diamond seemed pouch cradles your jewels gives you stuff to support it
needs without feeling too tight.
Female hosts read this and further ladies me on these features.
Soft plaque theme that minimizes slippage,
grows without sacrificing style.
You Pussy lips that coming out there and they're super comfy and every cut
Bikini Thong boy short or cheeky brief.
What the fuck is that? A what's a cheeky brief?
Is that a fucking some sorta English clamp? Um, it's simple.
If you don't love your me undies there, free CTA, whatever that means.
Now until August 31st get 20% off your first pair plus free shipping at me.
undies.com/ [inaudible] that's me. undies.com/bar. Hey me,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr nuclear, nuclear,
nuclear. I just like that better. Pro Flowers,
plow flowers, motherfucker. Um, hey,
there's no reason to get anybody flowers this month. That's why you do it.
You know? Hey fellas, you want to shut her up?
You sick or saying is no spice in the relationship?
Get a bouquet of, or is it bulky of roses? Right?
I don't like roses. I always get the fucking yellow ones. Tulips.
Tulips are great. They brighten up the fucking room. They actually smell nice.
You know what I mean? I love the tulips. You get them the nice yellow ones,
right? It reminds them of the fucking j Lo diamond, right? A Kobe's wife,
the diamond she got, that's what they remember. You know what I mean? All right.
I don't want to talk. I almost fucking went too far on that one.
I was going to talk about where you then put the flowers and what you use as a
face and I'm not going do that cause I'm going to be a little more classy.
All right. Throw flowers.
Talk about the last time you spontaneously surprised someone with something
completely unexpected and how it felt. Uh,
I, I, you know, I try,
I try to fucking surprise my wife. I can't, she's too perceptive.
She figures everything out. It's fucking unbelievable.
I can't even tell this story. It's too fucking embarrassing.
I can't even tell you. But like I didn't my fucking way.
I moved something around and it was just something sitting on the winds of sill
in a room full of 5,000 knickknacks and it was literally there for 20 minutes
and she came while she goes, what is the blah, blah, blah.
They went on the fucking window selves and I just went, like, I said, you know,
fuck you. Fuck you for being so and perceptive all the time.
You have another fucking guy in the house.
It take me three days before I realized that. Well, he wasn't a plumber. Um,
alright. Pro Flowers wants to help you surprise someone for no reason.
All the while. Also surprising you with a special deal. For my listeners,
get 20% off any fucking goddamn computer.
Come on, 20% off any unique summer rose boot, Keyes, rose bouquets,
bouquets, bouquets,
or any other bouquet bouquet bouquet for two and $29 a month.
Now I've said it too many times, I can't hear it the word anymore.
They're colorful. Rainbow Roses are always a hit.
If you aren't sure what to send someone pro flowers, bouquets.
That's how you said our guaranteed to stay fresh for at least seven days or your
money back and your control and you control the delivery day.
Pro Flowers gives you more bloom for the buck.
Big beautiful flowers with stems for your money with more stems for your money
to get 20% off your summer roses or any other bouquet of $29 or more.
Or go to proflowers.com and use my promo code Burra checkout.
That's pro flowers.com and code burr.
Don't wait to make somebody stay. You know, when I was a kid,
you just make them a mixtape like your boombox with a fucking side-by-side
tapes. You know that's what you do. That's what you do. All right, Helix.
Alex, I'm your unique, you know,
walk like anyone else talk like anyone else, church, church,
or sleep like anyone else. So why is your mattress?
Why is your mattress one size fit all?
Because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 fucking
dollars. Until now. Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions and they'll run a 3d biomechanical model
model of your body through the proprietary algorithms they developed with the
help of the world's leading era Gomix and biomechanic experts. The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on,
and a robot being built in your exact image.
How is customers reporting 30% improvement in overall sleep quality?
And for couples, they customize each side of the mattress. Who's kidding?
Who the love is slowly die? Why not fucking, you know,
begin your divorce by getting two different kinds of mattresses in one.
Begin your separate lives with your own customized side of your mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
And then after a while you get that little divider, you know, up in first class,
you guys ever get bumped up. Brady's fucking thing that'll ever happen to you.
Grip. You know what?
Short of Jesus coming back and you find out that you did enough fucking good
deeds that you get saved or whatever your religion is.
Mom had comes back and does something fucking uh, Abraham,
Buddha, l, Ron Hubbard, whoever, you,
whoever you wait for whoever you wait in for it comes back. Okay?
The only thing that's the only thing better than if that's shit's true, right?
The only thing better is fucking,
you know that little you get bumped up to first class,
you know that little fucking divider, you know,
and you fly across country next to somebody for six hours and you don't say one
fucking word to each other. All right? If you want to experience that at home,
you get a customized mattress either side. That's the same thing.
And turn your loved one into a complete stranger.
Your mattress arrives at your door, right about a week in shipping is free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about Heloc
sleep. You have 100 nights to try it out, and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and give you 100% refund. No questions asked.
Go to helix, sleep.com/bird get $50 off your order.
That's Heloc sleep.com/bar he likes sleep.com/bar
and lastly, but not leastly, stamps.com the headliner,
they always go on last. No one can follow this read. It's nice. It's quick,
it's succinct. I usually don't stumble over it. Okay.
I'm like the post office stamps.com never closes. Ooh,
shots fired. Unlike those pussies down the street, we keep going.
This is the 24 hours of Lamont's. I'm fucking shipping.
Print postage for lettuce or packages at your convenience.
24 seven key words slash, descriptors. Convenient, easy,
reliable, and flexible. That's how I'm going to sell it. Guys.
I'm going to use one of those adjectives each.
Each sentence stamped [inaudible] brings all the services of the U s post office
right to your fingertips. Jay's, his dad's convenient.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer. Wow, that's easy.
stamps.com makes it easy. Fuck, I just said that.
They'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates exact postage.
Wow. That's reliable.
stamps.com will even help you decide the best class of mail on your needs.
Jesus. That's flexible.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm fucking selling posters,
I'm going to warm myself out.
I use stamps.com and I'm a Maura if I can figure it out. So can you right now,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with this special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthepageandtypeinburkethatstampsdotcomenterburststamps.com
never go to the post office again. All right, we're done. Right?
We get through it all. Beautiful, beautiful, beautiful. 20 minutes to go.
20 minutes to go and I talk about everything I wanted to talk about a did I
mention Paul Versey has a standup special than all things comedy network is
going to be producing our first stand up special and the buzz on the road is
versus out there killing it. Like I knew he was gonna. All right.
August 13th at the Tarrytown theater in beautiful Tarrytown,
New York. Picturesque Tom Hanks.
Fucking sleepless in Seattle. Look at fucking place, right.
Um, me and uh, Hey god,
Dennis fucking computer. It's fucking screen.
Keeps shutting off. Me and Pete Davidson. Let me get this back on me.
There we go. Alright, me and Pete Davidson will be, uh,
we'll be the sort of the masters of ceremony. We've been warming up,
going out on stage together, giving each other's shed,
trying out new jokes fucking around.
I'm going to try to come out there in between shows.
I don't want to slow down the taping, but I will definitely get out there,
sign whatever you got, take some pictures or whatever.
And I'll try to move it along. Um, or whatever, you know,
whatever I can do to, to fucking interact. We have a few seats left.
I want to sell this thing out. It's really important I for Paul and uh,
the all things comedy network. So, uh, I'd appreciate it if he got the time.
He want to listen. Listen to a, you know, some comedy. Come on down August 13th.
All right. Plowing ahead and I'll be at the count base.
He theater this weekend out in Jersey, out in New Jersey, Red Bank,
New Jersey. Um, which is really beautiful.
I might go down to Asbury Park during the day.
I have no idea what I'm going to do. Um, cause I usually stay in the city.
I think I'm going to fucking stay at somewhere out in jersey, you know.
Okay.
Maybe I'll call fucking, what's his face for any brand? Any brand has a boat.
I'm terrified of the ocean going to go out in the fucking ocean with a Goddamn
club owner. Why not? All right. Okay. Here we go.
The probably with North Korea, deer,
Ronald McDonald balls.
North Korea is a serious threat to East Asia and now two good.
A portion of the world. I understand that.
So what, so all week, so are we,
you know, if you've got to play this, you know what I mean? Like,
like everybody that said that patriots cheated. If you gonna play that game,
then you got to see the cheating that you're doing. Correct. Am I nuts here?
Am I crazy? Yes. The missile tests the other day was a ballistic missile,
but they can put a nuclear weapon on it as well. Okay.
And so can we, we already, we already have ours ready to go.
Their latest test puts most of the u s all of Europe and a good portion of
Africa within range of their weapons. Yes.
In all of those places are in range of our weapons and Russia's weapons.
So,
you know, I mean, look,
I'm not saying it's great that this guy has his fucking thing,
but just imagine if he had what we had, what the fuck would we be doing?
Wouldn't we be doing the same fucking thing? Well, we gotta get some stuff.
He ain't, he's making that shit cause we got our shit
right.
It's like when the Yankees started spending 200 million fucking dollars,
the red sox had to spend one 90. That's what happens. That's what happens.
Um,
yeah.
And if they are actually able to successfully launched from a submarine as they
are attempting to do this, this not only increases the range,
but can potentially dramatically increase the amount of time we have to respond.
If they were to launch a missile. Well what, what would happen, sir?
Okay.
Listen, everybody knows there's no end game to this shit. Okay? It's good.
It's going to be over. We would have time to respond.
Don't you remember what the fuck was at war games?
I can't believe how seriously people are fucking taking this shit.
Like I don't think this guy's out of his fucking mind in North Korea. Alright.
I'm just so fucking sick of, of,
of having to turn on the TV and have somebody has to try it.
It's like news now is just scare the shit out of somebody and offer no fucking
solutions.
And then normal people just sit there screaming at each other to the point that
this fucking dope is taking the time to turn my podcast,
which is supposed to be a break from all of that shit,
which is why I just say silly shit about it. You turn this into meet the press,
okay.
If that fucking asshole shoots one off pointed right at my house,
cause I don't want to survive it.
I don't give a fuck. Alright?
We have no one to blame but ourselves.
Okay,
we're fucking defective. If you went beings were cars, we would all be recalled.
All right? We do not handle position of power. Well,
and this is what the fuck happens. All right?
We're fearful fucking lunatics who for some stupid reason,
we're given the ability to fucking intimidate nerds so they would build all this
shit for us. And now here we are.
Here we are. All right.
North Korea also has the highest percentage of slaves in the world fully like
you care, sir. Like you give a shit fully.
4.4% of its population is in slave that it's approximately 1.1 million. Sir,
I am on an apple fucking computer right now and I'm sure you typed yours on an
apple computer too. Those people are jumping out of the factory there.
They're fucking slaves.
All the shit that I'm wearing was made in sweatshops.
Like what are we doing now? Now we're going to fudge the fucking numbers.
So these people look like they're out of their minds,
but everybody else is fucking okay.
This is like coming countries or like community colleges where they will figure
out what their number one and so they can fucking put it in there. Yeah.
Pamphlet. Um, okay,
let's read some more fucking depressing information.
This is why I don't watch the news, um, today did that today.
And that doesn't even mention the network of concentration cramps across the
nation. And the people getting less than some,
less than subsistence levels of daily calories. Well, I mean,
they're also not allowed to trade with anybody, are they? You know,
they really can't get this shit going. Right. I mean,
part of that is us trying to force them into giving in to get in forever 21
Starbucks there. Isn't that right? I mean, I might be wrong.
So I fucking watch sports. I watch sports, I listen to music.
Okay, I block all this shit up. So I'm sure I mispronounced some words here.
To put that into perspective,
about that 388,000 slaves were shipped to North America from 1525 to eight 900
1866 it's obviously a huge issue.
Well, how do you,
how do you put that in perspective without telling me what the population of
Korea is and also 388,000 people back in between 1525 and 1866 was a way more
significant portion of the population than it is today. Correct.
So I don't know what you're saying there, sir.
But I do know that whenever we have an issue with the country,
all of a sudden we pretend to care about its people. Unfortunately,
there isn't any easy solution to the problem.
Even if China withdraws their support and the regime regime collapses,
you're still looking at a potential civil war in a nation with nuclear weapons.
Let's just hope people smarter than you are.
I can find a different solution to the problem and that they won't,
there's only one solution. Got To go in there and get them. Uh,
keep up the good work. I love hearing you talk about us,
how awesome it is to be a parent instead of constant talk about how hard it is
as a dad of two boys.
There are obviously days when I feel like ripping out what little hair I have
left, but the vast, vast majority of the time is just awesome. Uh, look at this.
He was actually just informing me and I got all fucking defensive because all
this week people said that I said nuclear instead of nuclear. Um, yes sir.
I realize he's out of his fucking mind.
I realized that person's out of his fucking mind. The Guy Before him,
his dad was out of his fucking mind. Okay. Trump is out of his fucking mind.
I'm out of my fucking mind. Okay.
Nobody should have weapons other than you fucking fists and whatever you can
grab in the kitchen. That's ideally, that's what, that would be better.
All right. I think,
I don't understand why war is legal, but it is.
So this is the game that we play with each other and it is fucking inevitable
that one day somebody is going to go Martin Sheen dead zone.
And what are you going to do? You know?
See people, this is why I have all four sports packages
because I don't want to know about this shit.
I don't want to fucking sit here and watch the news and have them scare the
living shit out of me that now this is going to happen, you know,
and some flies going to bite me and then I'm gonna have a baby with a little
head. Somebody else is gonna fucking blow me up. It just, I,
I just, yeah, I don't want to, I don't want to talk about this. Okay.
Trying to keep it light on the podcast here. Let's just make,
let's just laugh at me not being able to pronounce words.
Don't bring actual facts into this podcast. All right,
girls softball, team punished. Um, hey there Billy batting glove.
Did you hear about the girl's softball team that was removed from the world
series because of a,
a picture of some of the players flicking off the camera on social media.
One of the girls on the team is the daughter of a family friend.
It's fucking brutal. Um, yeah.
I mean, I don't, I don't know. I don't know what,
I don't understand social media.
I'm Kinda over it other than for business purposes.
I don't just don't think it's a good thing.
That should've just been a funny picture that they all took shared amongst
themselves,
but now you upload it and everybody sees it and you know somebody's going to get
offended.
Let me guess what they the best where they probably were the number one seed.
This sounds like if one of those bad news bears things, um,
they removed from the world series. Well, well, you know how,
you know people are there trying to make money.
They make money off that world series. Is it a national thing? I don't know.
It's like the Colin Kaepernick thing.
Everybody's fucking flipping out and immediately thinking that this guy's not
getting hired because of racism. It's like the NFL is a fucking corporation.
Okay. You know what? They give a fuck about money. Now look,
if he was trying to get a coaching job or own a team, then yeah,
I would say racism would be more obvious. But like what he does,
most of the league is black doing okay.
Their thing is they're such cheap fucking cunts.
They would rather lose a fucking game.
They probably have an algorithm going like, okay,
if we get this guy and he wins a few more games,
how many jerseys where we sell versus the amount of people who won't buy a
Jersey because we signed this guy and I swear to God, if, if,
if we'll sell a fucking jersey less by signing a guy who would actually make us
a better fucking team, I sweated God, they will decide not to sign the guy.
I don't think, I'm not saying this isn't racist with them involved,
but it's really, it's fucking economics.
And what these fucking corporations try to do is they,
they don't want any bullshit.
They want smooth fucking water. That's what they want.
Everybody fucking just tow the fucking line. That's what they want.
And I'll tell you all these fucking groups that are trying to make change. No,
that shit.
Which is why they always complain to the advertisers because the advertisers
will then pull sponsorship from TV shows. They'll do it from fucking podcast.
Everybody knows that. So the NFL is a corporation, so that's what they're doing.
I don't know what the fuck league these girls are in,
but I'm sure they have some sort of stupid conduct thing that they're trying to,
you know, trying to uphold. Yeah, it's fucking stupid.
It's also fucking stupid to upload that picture. I mean,
how many of these dumb stories you're going to see where people get offended by
absolutely nothing and then something happens. Right?
A that's unfortunate. It's unfortunate. All right, Trent Reznor.
This is like a way more serious podcast than I ever want to do. I don't know.
I don't really have to do and I'm going to just start making up shit here.
I try to read the news, but it's just all depressing.
Although the funny one was all this shit coming out about Lady Diana.
Now I just don't understand how new evidence 20 years later they're finding,
they found out that fucking Sheila was listening to Prince Charles Jerking off,
talking to some other lady on a toilet.
Did somebody have that tape for fucking 20 years going, hey dude,
listen to this. I swear to God, don't tell anybody I have this.
I'm going to release it when the time is right.
And then you just hear the echoing sound of Prince Charles going right.
I'm going to put in your ass. You are. Um, all right,
Trent Reznor article, a bully, bully, bully,
bully a thought you could relate to this.
Trent Reznor talks about what it's like to meet his parents.
Kids.
You meant to say his kids' parents while having a body of work with lyrics.
Like I want to fuck you like an animal. Yeah, I read that article. But um,
okay.
Never underestimate the power of celebrity. And especially, I don't know,
he's an older dad, so maybe they don't even know what his fucking music is,
but you know,
I wouldn't give a shit. I sang, I downloaded that, fuck it.
So I fucking loved his stuff.
That shit came out like that album blew my fucking mind. And I'd be like,
that's Trent fucking Reznor. They sweetheart. That's Trent fucking resonate.
I wouldn't give it a shit, you know, but it's gotta be weird.
But then there's of course the people that don't like it,
you know the people that were at like the four h club
and you know, what did he do?
He wanted to fuck someone like an animal and he expressed it all right.
Cart girlfriend cheating after joining the military.
And I legally can't leave her. What? She's your girlfriend?
All right, dear Billy Ball balls. He's a good this week you guys usually,
you know, lately there's been a little drought. He's a fucking funny this week.
All right. Greetings from Scotland. Uh,
recently I quit my well paying job to join the British Royal Marines.
My girlfriend had four years,
was very hesitant and didn't want me to leave,
but it had been a dream of mine since I was 14.
I sat her down a week before leaving and gave her the opportunity to separate,
wait,
my girlfriend and four years was very hesitant and didn't want me to leave but
had been dreaming since I as far as okay.
I sat down with her a week before leaving and gave her the opportunity to
separate on good terms and maybe continue our relationship on.
I had finished my mandatory four years service,
but if we stayed together but we stay.
If we stayed together and she cheated, she would be dead to me.
I'm half Sicilian by the way. Uh, she chose to stay.
Um, the fact that you would given her the option to leave, I mean,
how much do you give a shit about this woman?
I was in for just over four weeks and fell during a run and is six,
six months. Serve a guy, stood on my leg,
breaking my Tibia in two places. Oh fuck.
I was given the choice of staying in medical custody on base and rejoin training
when I had healed or leaving for a year.
I chose to leave so I can spend more time with my girlfriend. Oh.
Oh. I thought it would be nice surprised to not tell her I was coming home. Oh,
Jesus. I arrived home around 9:00 PM on Thursday. Oh my God.
To find my girl out. Jesus choking on some guy's Dick.
Wow. So what he's to do, throw your fucking crutches at him.
Naturally. My instinct was to beat the shit out of the guy,
but I'm not too mobile with a pair of crutches.
I forced the two out of my house and kept my promise of you're dead to me by
changing the locks the next morning and blocking her number and social media
accounts around. Two weeks later,
I received a letter from a lawyer saying that if I don't take her back,
she can legally take half of all my assets,
including the house my mother left me in her will because we had been together
for more than two years. What?
I thought you had to be married, but low and behold,
the British justice system does me another solid.
I could understand if I was away on tour from nine months and she cheated,
but four weeks fucking four weeks. You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Should I just take the loss and leave this dumb whore?
What do I take her back and try to forget the fact that she took the first
opportunity she had to jump on jump another guy's bone. Your bones,
your input would be great and maybe can put a funny twist on this fucked up
opportunity for your listeners. Dude, you need to get a fucking lawyer.
You need to get that bitch out of your life and get a fucking lawyer.
That's what you need to do.
All right.
That is one of the dumbest laws I've ever heard in my life and that's going to
cause.
That's going to cause people to make some really fucked up decisions if someone
can screw him that fucking bad. All right,
over here I found a statutory, a statutory rape. What is it?
What is it? What is the fucking law when you've been illegally married?
That's squatter's rights. What the fuck is it? I don't know. Why are we here?
It's like you gotta be living with somebody for like seven years,
depending on the state. Um, and at that point they considered,
it's so dumped, they, that she's entitled to half you shit.
Especially if she's not making any money and you're fucking paying for
everything, you know? Um,
oh, it's fucking ridiculous. What a fucking cunt.
You know what I mean? I mean,
how many fucking stories do they do out there about men beating women and how
awful men are to fucking women, right?
Which obviously they got to shine a light on that, but look at that. She's,
she's gonna just fucking whore. Who sucked?
This other guy's Dick doesn't could care less about taking half of the House
that your mother left you.
Oh my God. What a fucking cunt dude. I would get a lawyer.
I would get all my, I would get a fucking lawyer. What a fucking piece of shit,
dude. Like, I don't know.
I can't make this is like making me angry that someone could do that to
somebody. What kind of a piece of shit?
Yeah, the kind of person that fucking blow somebody for week seven.
But even then, there's plenty of women that would do that.
There's plenty of fucking women that would do that.
They wouldn't take your fucking house. They will raise, right.
If they get caught, suck in a deck, they guy, you know, fair enough.
And they leave Jesus cry. We'll get a lawyer, sir.
I would get a lawyer and I would fucking fight this thing.
Find some fucking thing that, oh my God.
Okay.
The advice that I want to give you,
I can't say over this because I'll be liable. Okay. And it's like,
all right, let me tell, let me tell the fucking little story here. Um,
no I can't. I can't do it.
I can't tell the story cause I'll get in fucking trouble. I won't Sir.
You know what? I would get a lawyer and handle it legally.
Don't do anything fucking crazy. All right. Jesus Christ. What I can't do,
I'll tell you right there, man. You, you met one for the ages.
That's a first ballot hall of fame con. If I ever fucking heard of one,
good Lord,
I could see if she caught you and then out a vindictiveness then did that, that,
you know, they'd be like, wow, you know what the fuck.
But she's going to do that and then take half your fucking house.
And you know what kills me when she tells the story. She a,
I'm not saying she'll play the, she won't be in the rock.
I mean that's a fucking psychopath.
Okay.
Thank God you didn't breed with her man. Jesus fucking Christ.
Jesus Christ. Well, you know what? Thank you for your service, sir.
You know what?
These whores can take everything you've got and there's nothing you can fucking
do about it. That's how the laws are set up. And I gotta be honest with you,
dude. You know, worst case scenario,
if she takes your half your house and half the shit,
even still considering what the fuck they can do to you,
you actually got off easy, easier than a lot of guys did.
But Jesus Christ can,
I apologize for this podcast. I don't want to get involved in world politics.
I don't want to talk about North Korea.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about. You know what I mean?
And for the 18 people that are going to take any of this shit fucking seriously,
I don't give a shit. Let's just keep it to correcting my fucking spelling.
Shall We? Um, I'm going to end this fucking podcast on an upbeat note.
It's Joe d Rose's birthday today at goddammit.
He's coming home from fucking Amsterdam. I've got happy birthday,
Joey Rose's happy birthday, Joey roses. Oh,
I can't even, I can't sing the song. If you ever heard this fucking songs,
we sing to each other. I mean, just,
I'm trying to think of a group that would be offended by, well,
I know the one group in particular, um, I,
I literally can't even sing him the fuck. This is just whole thing.
Just went off the fucking rails.
This whole podcast went off the rails because that was one that was such a
fucking, do you know what I did? You know,
because I've been stuck in the writer's room and I haven't been going out and
doing stand up and seeing people.
You'd have the stories to tell you what I do before I get on the podcast now as
I just click on Google news and it's just the most horrific shit.
You know that fucking ride that broke in Ohio.
Fucking 18 year old kid died.
Kid was born in 1999 died going to a fucking amusement park.
Somebody blew up a mosque, tried to and fucking Minneapolis.
I don't understand how people sit there and they watch CNN and Fox and all that
shit. Just like what? What does it do for you to stay informed? I,
I didn't have a fucking, I don't know what it'd be fucking,
I didn't want to say it. I want to sit the fuck I would be doing. I, I, I,
it's just not fun anymore. I got, you know, when I got to do,
I'm going to watch, I promise you guys,
I'm just going to watch sports between now and Thursday and I,
I'm going to do something. I'm going to go to a mall or something.
I'll just make fun of fat people when I get back.
I apologize for the heaviness of this podcast. All right, go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday over there.